alors de manière globale on peut dire
que l'unité syndicale et associative a
fait un petit pas mais il ne s'agit que
nos petits pas puisque nous avons
absolument besoin d'un ensemble de
contrats aidés beaucoup plus importants
pour pouvoir satisfaire les besoins au
sein des établissements scolaires
je rappelle que pour les 500 ce sont des
500 éducation nationale ce qui veut dire
que à peu près les problèmes de vie
scolaire que l'on n'évoquait ils ne sont
pas complètement réglé parce qu'il va
manquer encore des personnels et à
certains personnels qui n'auront pas
certains établissements scolaires qui
n'auront pas suffisamment de personnel
en vie scolaire encore mais c'est un
petit pas quand même mais par contre
l'autre aspect qu'on avait développé
c'est à dire l'aspect hygiène l'aspect
nettoyage des établissements cuisine etc
il n'est pas du tout régler donc on ne
peut pas être satisfait de ces seulement
500 contrats supplémentaires ça ne
change strictement rien pour nous à la
mobilisation du jeudi 21 c'est à dire
celle de demain parce que pour l'instant
la satisfaction pour l'éducation
nationale mais je rappelle qu'on est
l'unité syndicale et associative donc il
ya les syndicats de l'éducation
nationale
il y a les syndicats de la territoriale
et les ja les associations donc on a
besoin de l'ensemble de ces contrats
pour fonctionner convenablement sur le
territoire et pour mettre un petit peu
de beurre dans les épinards de certaines
familles qui sont dans la détresse